problema 20 en una librería los libros
que normalmente cuestan de pesos tienen
un descuento de 10 pesos cuando están en
oferta ok entonces regularmente cada
libro cuesta de pesos esto es su precio
normal
y cuestan 10 pesos menos es decir ve
menos 10 cuando están en oferta aquí lo
voy a poner cuando están en oferta
oferta
y la pregunta es cuánto costará comprar
tres de estos libros en oferta bueno
pues ya sabemos el precio de uno basta
multiplicar este precio por tres es
decir lo que tendríamos que pagar es
tres veces b menos 10 eso está en las
opciones 3b menos 10 no 3 b más 10 no
aquí está 3 x v10 entonces sería la
opción c otra forma de escribir esto es
distribuyendo el 3-3 por vez sería 3 b
luego sería menos y 3 por 10 sería 30
pero esta forma no está escrita acá
afortunadamente estuvo esta que
obtuvimos primero bueno la respuesta es
si vamos al siguiente problema
problema 21 dice si una línea recta pasa
por los puntos y ve que se muestran a
continuación aproximadamente y eso suena
importante aproximadamente dónde va a
cortar dicha línea recta al eje x bueno
aquí tenemos el punto a y el punto b y
tenemos que unir los para construir la
recta más o menos debería quedar algo
como así como así sale y la pregunta es
dónde va a cortar esta línea recta al
eje x más o menos veo que la
intersección queda por este punto de acá
bueno veamos nuestras opciones la a dice
entre menos 3 y menos 2 pues si esto
suena muy bien verdad justo parece que
corto ahí si hubiera otra opción que se
acerque un poco más voy a tener que ser
un poco más cuidadoso pero mientras
tanto entre menos 3 y menos 2 parece ser
una buena opción la opción b dice entre
cero y menos uno entre cero y menos uno
es como por acá y definitivamente no
corta verdad por muy fea que haya hecho
que haya hecho mi aproximación
por ahí entonces esta no es la opción se
dice entre 0 y 1 no tampoco está no es y
finalmente la de dice entre 1 y 2 pues
mucho menos está que da más a la derecha
entonces esta tampoco es la respuesta
sería la opción
muy bien vamos al problema de aquí
arriba el problema 22 nos preguntan qué
expresión es equivalente a 7 a cuadrada
b por 7 bs cuadrada déjame copiarlo por
acá sería 7 a cuadrado b
7 b
se cuadrada aquí lo que vamos a utilizar
es que la multiplicación es conmutativa
es decir podemos reacomodar los factores
como nosotros querramos déjame empezar
poniendo los números tengo este 7 y este
7 entonces los voy a poner acá como 7
por 7 este 7 y este 7 como 7 por 7 luego
voy a poner a
sería cuadrada luego lo que tenga ve
esta vez con esta vez a cuadrada por b
por b y finalmente voy a poner estas e
cuadrada porsche cuadrada bueno ahora
tenemos que hacer las operaciones aquí 7
por 7 es 49
a cuadrada está cuadrada ve por vez ve
cuadrada y se cuadrada pues s cuadrada
entonces la respuesta sería 49 a
cuadrada b cuadradas e cuadrada bueno
vamos a ver si esto está entre las
opciones no no aquí está 49 cuadrada b
cuadradas e cuadrada entonces la
respuesta sería c